welcome to the stream another huge day
in politics I know that there are people
who also want to talk about the
hour-long Dave Rubin interview that was
just posted to our YouTube channel so
we're gonna have time for all of that
and just so many things going on the
title for this stream at least the part
about Trump bans transgender military is
sadly true the guy who said he would be
a friend the LGBT community has
announced via Twitter which now is you
know weirdly a place where policy is
announced that you will not be allowed
to be in the military in any capacity if
you are a transgender individual and I
talked a little bit on the broadcast
show today about the absurdity of that
if you haven't checked out the podcast
or any of the other platforms so far I'm
gonna dig into that a little bit as well
and yeah there's just a lot going on and
I want to tell you about what's coming
up on the show and I mean there's just
so many different things that are going
on right now not the least of which is
that this is a YouTube livestream and if
this is your first YouTube livestream I
do want to welcome you and thank you for
joining me
we're live right now I'm talking to you
meaning that you're able to talk to me
the way to do that and most easily is to
use the super chat function the super
chat function is the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window you are able
to send questions that you want me to
answer you are able to send comments
that you want me to read and react to
all of that is more than welcome through
the super chat the regular chat often
moves way too quickly to keep up with
but I will every once in a while be able
to pick up something from there but
super chat is greater than if you've got
comments about the Dave Rubin interview
I know a lot of people have been saying
David I really want to talk about that
people have strong feelings about it
super chats a good spot for that also
any new members or patrons during the
stream will get live shoutouts and
thank-yous from me we will have a
patreon a pledge challenge which I will
announce shortly which if it is achieved
I will release a mage
membership discount code but in the
meantime you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership support the
work that we do you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a modest forty percent
discount you can also make a pledge of
as little as a dollar a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
lastly seriously don't troll last last
time I did the livestream which I think
was two days ago
day before yesterday people were banned
from our YouTube channel before the the
livestream even started about a minute
before we had people people blocked
already so the moderators are here
they've been fully empowered to block
and ban people as they see fit
and there's going to be you might hear
things here that might trigger you this
is not a safe space for the alt-right or
for trumpets or for extremist
conservatives so just be aware that you
might get banned you might get banned
okay
so Donald Trump has announced on Twitter
I mentioned this during today's program
that he is saying no transgender people
in the military period and this presents
a number of problems number one what do
you do with the ones that are already
there there are a couple different
estimates that are floating around
anywhere between 1,500 and 6,000
transgender service members currently
out of the 1.2 million active duty
people the RAND Corporation put a more
precise number on it they said two
thousand four hundred and fifty and
Donald Trump cited a couple of different
concerns and I'm treating his tweets as
if they really deserve serious analysis
despite just being the offhanded
utterances of a clueless madman but
let's explore it one of the things he
mentioned is this idea of the medical
expense of having transgender
individuals in the military now of
course there's a couple different
aspects to that one is whether there are
individuals who are transitioning in the
military and they want something like
gender reassignment surgery but when
you're talking about individuals who are
transgender and have already
transitioned
and are now in the military what there's
really no cost there right and the RAND
Corporation has estimated that we're
talking about a sub half of one percent
of the total military budget when it
comes to a medical budget rather when it
comes to particular medical services for
transgender individuals so it's really
kind of a bogus argument you could save
way more by you know shutting down half
of the dozens and dozens of bases that
we have in Germany many of which we'd be
safe without so the cost argument is
really a non-starter and then you have
this question of well in what way does
having a transgender individual in the
military affect our ability to have
these decisive wins that Donald Trump
talked about and I've seen no serious
explanation as to that you know it
reminds me of there was a Saturday Night
Live this was a while ago there was a
Saturday Night Live impression done of
Newt Gingrich by I believe it was
Darrell Hammond and when doing this just
fake impersonation of Newt Gingrich he
said something like well you can't have
women in the military because you know
they've got that vagina that was
basically the argument and it's of
course a ridiculous argument and now we
have women in the military and many of
our allies including Israel have had
women gay men lesbian women transgender
people in the military for a very long
time and everything's fine and there's
no problem so that's the other place
where this doesn't really make sense and
it seems like it's a deliberate effort
to distract from the endless scandals
the attempt to take away health care
from 10 percent of the American
population via a repeal of the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare the
investigation the possibility of firing
Jeff Sessions or at least trying to get
him to resign on his own Rex Tillerson
Secretary of State is now thinking of
resignation it's a disaster right and
this is a play this is a double-edged
play for Trump once it's an attempt to
appeal to maybe that Trump is base which
might be homophobic but might just like
the idea of Trump doing things that
anger liberals because that's a lot of
why Trump ists like Trump if you
actually asked them and I talked
my program all the time I asked them
well what what do you like so far that
Trump is done very quickly that line of
questioning breaks down into just just
mumbling and and you know total totally
inept responses what they like about
Trump is that liberals are pissed
and the reason liberals are pissed is
because they're worried about the
country and where Trump is taking it and
because clearly if you're a progressive
you're going to be displeased with
Donald Trump saying no transgender
people in the military that might be a
way to appeal to that hardcore Trump is
base and then there's the distraction
element that I mentioned the idea that
things are not going well for Donald
Trump but all approval rating in the
dumps has accomplished nothing it's just
a total and utter disaster and this
would be a way to try to distract from
that so questions still outstanding is
this a policy the Pentagon agrees with
Trump said he consulted with generals
but as we learned from reading a number
of analyses already consulted with
generals might mean ask generals their
opinion and then did what he wanted to
do no matter what consulted could mean
told generals this is what I'm doing be
prepared for it
that could be a consultation so what is
the view of the Pentagon and of the
generals or as Trump called them his
generals and also was the Pentagon aware
that Trump was going to release this
policy on Twitter today
unclear still unclear if they had any
idea that this was coming let me jump
into the Super chats and then I'll talk
a little bit about the Dave Rubin
interview Daryl Dudley has sent the $5
super chat do you think Trump will do a
recess appointment for sessions so that
he can stop the Moller investigation
good question I mentioned yesterday on
the program that Donald Trump the timing
of Donald Trump wanting Jeff Sessions to
resign or thinking about firing Jeff
Sessions could be because then Trump
might think and I whether Trump has any
idea about this I have no idea
Trump might think oh the House and
Senate are going into summer recess for
basically the entire month of August
I'll do a recess appointment then
there's a little bit of a problem with
that
the problem with that is that you can
have what's called a pro forma session
any member of Congress of the Senate can
even during recess show up and start a
pro forma session which prevents these
recess appointments so if that's what
Donald Trump is banking on Darryl it
could fail very very easily and Donald
Trump has banked on bogus strategies
before so it wouldn't really be a
surprise
Frank macwrite has sent the $20 super
chat saying many Trump interviewees call
out CNN MSNBC etc for talking only about
Trump Russia or being obsessed with
Trump's Twitter what else is there what
real positive things has he done what do
you think people need to know well
there's a couple different aspects to
that right Frank I mean on the one hand
the Twitter thing I find to be it's a
really bogus critique to say media and
in fact Dave Rubin said this yesterday
during our interview and I disagreed
with it then and I disagree with it now
this idea that being obsessed with
Trump's Twitter is a bad thing we have
for the first time major changes to
policy to actions and activities of the
government being announced on Twitter
directly by the President of the United
States I would argue that by covering
what the president is saying on Twitter
we have a far more direct line to what
it is that the president is at least
attempting to do than we've had before
where we have no choice but to go
through prepared press releases and
statements from you know the deputy
press secretary or whoever so I think
that the critique that it's that that
media outlets are incorrectly obsessed
with Trump's Twitter is a completely
bogus critique it's a flaccid critique
it's a critique that has absolutely no
testicular fortitude behind it excuse
the term and I welcome that debate with
anybody who wants to have it what else
do people need to know there's a lot
right I mean there is a lot to talk
about Frank beyond just Trump Russia and
Trump's Twitter
health care tax it tax plans
it's endless right and I'm doing
everything I can to talk about it
including a lot of the things that
Republicans are trying to do quietly
while Trump is in the in the middle of a
bunch of scandals PA Barry
double-oh-seven five-dollar super chat
said isn't it cute how Donald Trump said
he would be better for LGBT freedom than
crooked Hillary and yet he is doing the
exact opposite with his tweet yeah and
and people I guess this is a good time
as I need to get into the Dave Rubin
interview of some people pointed out
that yesterday Dave Rubin said listen
even though I am for LGBT rights and as
he said he's married to a man himself
that he thinks that that the whole issue
of LGBT rights is not really a thing
anymore well day after that interview
Donald Trump says yet transgender people
now banned from the military on the
basis of having a gender identity that
doesn't align with their birth genitalia
so clearly that that was not an aspect
of the interview that many of our
viewers agreed with but let me talk a
little more about the Dave Rubin
interview if you haven't seen this
interview yesterday we did something
different on the broadcast show instead
of having a short interview in 7:00 or
so of the day's news stories we did the
full hour which when you take away
commercial breaks is about 51 minutes we
had the full hour with dave rubin dave
rubin an increasingly controversial
figure right and dave rubin someone I've
known for a while and I really enjoyed
the conversation I had with him we were
able to talk about his political
philosophy I was able to ask him some
more specific questions about how he's
running his program the Rubin report and
the response has been all over the map
there were some people who were just
really angry with me believing that I
ran the interview in some really bad way
I was either too critical of dave rubin
or not critical enough of dave rubin or
whatever then there were a lot of people
who were not already familiar with dave
rubin and based on just the one
interview developed some kind of
perspective on dave rubin mostly
thinking that he is on the right and in
other words not not any kind of whatever
word you want to use progressive liberal
leftist etc
and then there were people who are just
furious with Dave Rubin because they
felt that he furious or just critical of
Dave Rubin saying he really didn't
answer questions that this just raised
more questions than were answered or
whatever the case may be and then there
were just like format comments like
David it's a bad idea to do an interview
for the entire our show or David it's a
good idea to do an interview for the
entire show once a week or once every
two weeks or whatever if you look at the
like/dislike ratio on a lot of these
videos way more dislikes in general than
what we would normally see on our
YouTube videos and it's sort of
deceptive because some of the dislikes
are people that don't like that I
interviewed Dave Rubin some of the
dislikes are people don't like how I
handle the interview some of the
dislikes are just because people don't
like what Dave Rubin said so I don't
know I encourage you to check it out we
released the interview in four parts
yesterday and we've now released all 51
minutes and 44 seconds of the interview
as one YouTube video and you can check
out the entire thing and then and then
let me know what you think and by all
means I'm glad to take comments during
the livestream about the Dave Rubin
interview god X of XPath has sent a $5
super chat saying how likely do you
think it is that we have our own
Saturday massacre do you think it would
have similar fallout - so the Saturday
night massacre was when Richard Nixon in
the throes of the Watergate scandal
started firing people himself and it it
correlated in many ways with sort of
where we increasingly are with the Trump
administration and the Russia
investigation I think that there is that
it's certainly possible that we would
see further firings and I've said I
don't believe that Jeff Sessions should
resign if Trump wants him out make Trump
fire him and if you had said to me six
months ago David in six months you will
be arguing that
Jeff Sessions shouldn't resign I would
have laughed in your face and said that
absolutely makes no sense but that's
exactly where I am today I'm saying Jeff
don't resign make Trump fire you because
that is going to grow the scandal and
and just even put even more attention on
what's going on the preaching show has
sent a $2 Super chat do you think this
ban I believe that you mean Donald
Trump's ban on transgender individuals
serving in the military is
unconstitutional I don't know I've not
read anything so far suggesting that
it's an unconstitutional ban but that
doesn't mean that such an argument could
be made but I will research that in time
for tomorrow's program Hobbiton has sent
a ten british pound super Chad David
people have been asking you to debate
Kyle : ski on Trump Russia for months
you keep on saying there's nothing to
debate but he's still denying it matters
are you stonewalling us no I'm not
stonewalling you I you know I'm willing
to talk to Kyle about Trump Russia and
we could just sort of figure out like
okay what what do we know and then how
how much does it matter I don't know
that we would get much out of it right I
mean the Dave Rubin interview was
interesting because there were a lot of
types of questions that Dave because of
the format of his show had not answered
that people wanted to hear answers to
and I think we got to that you can get
my view on Trump Russia on my channel
and Kyle's on his channel and it's
really just a disagreement in terms of
how serious of an issue do we think it
is I think it's quite serious and yet
believe that Democrats are completely
bungling this by not developing a
standalone platform that they can use in
2018 and 2020 I gather that Kyle doesn't
think it's a very serious issue and I'm
not sure where Kyle is on whether it
relates to the credibility of Bernie
Sanders as a candidate there's a lot of
stuff wrapped up in this for a lot of
people but I don't know that we would
really learn anything I guess is my
point it would just sort of be like okay
we don't agree so I'm open to talking to
him although I don't know how productive
it would be I guesses is my point of
view okay let me go over a couple of
other things we've got some some pretty
major things going on I hope to have
soon some good announcements to make
with regard to the recovery from the
YouTube advertiser boycott 30-second
summary March 31st which is marked by
number two on this chart the YouTube ad
boycott began we lost 99% of our ad
revenue needless to say this crushed us
and it actually represents a systemic
threat to the David Pakman show at a
time when I believe we need to be
supporting the widest possible range of
voices in media rather than narrow given
the attacks on net neutrality given the
attacks on media from the Trump
administration so it looked like we were
starting to recover if you look at point
three on this graph which is roughly mid
May and then at the end of June and the
beginning of July which is marked by 0.4
on the graph at the right side revenue
fell off a cliff again and we're down
about 85 percent so we've been going
about this in two ways and thankfully
there have been a number of really good
articles written about this in major
media outlets the New York Times for
example wrote a tremendous article
really well researched by Amanda Hess
called how YouTube's shifting algorithms
hurt independent media this article was
90% about the david pakman show an
article in The New York Times mostly
about our YouTube channel and how we
were affected by it you can read that
article to learn more about what's going
on it's on our web site the journalists
davey alba also wrote a great article a
month following that a New York Times
article in Wired magazine called want a
better web here's an idea
pay for it the long and short of it
whether you're looking at these articles
or at the revenue graph is that we may
well be dealing with the new normal
right we may now be in a in a new status
quo where our youtube channel will only
make about 15% of the revenue that it
once made and as a result what we're
doing is trying to fund the show in
other ways and I actually believe that
if we can succeed in this endeavor we
will be stronger than we were with our
full ad revenue because we will no
longer need to worry about what happens
on YouTube so one way you can support us
is by going to David
mancom slash membership where you can
sign up for as little as six dollars a
month or sixty for the year if those
rates strike you is too high
fret not because on page two of the
signup process you can put in the coupon
code
I voted seventeen and that'll give you a
40% discount but I want to propose one
other thing to you okay we also have
patreon as a platform on which we are
raising money and on patreon we're
really raising it $1 at a time you can
go to patreon and hit that red button
which says become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
you can make a pledge of $1 a month as
of the beginning of this livestream we
had 1833 patrons here is my offer to you
here's my proposal to you and by you I
mean the people on this livestream okay
this is who I'm talking to if we can get
to 1850 patrons by the end of this
stream I will create and release a major
discount code now we did this on Monday
for 1800 patrons and we made it and I
created a discount code that would save
you fifty five percent off of membership
just to show you that I am willing to
best that if we get to eighteen hundred
and fifty patrons by the end of this
stream I will create a coupon code that
will save you fifty six percent off of
membership okay I will create that
coupon code I will only tell you about
it it will not be announced on our
broadcast show or on our podcast or
anywhere else help us get to 1850
patrons and I will of course thank all
seventeen people who helped us do that
so let's let's get that going I will get
back into the politics and then we'll
check check in on that again a little
bit later u.s. senator Bernie Sanders is
checking in with a $2.00 super chat
saying hi David is that a snare drum in
the background and indeed it is this is
a snare drum there was a question about
it last time it's right here and it's a
5 inch snare drum with several practice
pads on top of it I've been playing
drums for probably I guess at this point
of close to
twelve or thirteen years played in a
band played in multiple bands in fact
one with former producer Louis where we
did alt rock and here in my apartment I
can't really have loud drums so what
I've done is taken an acoustic snare and
put a number of practice pads on it and
with those pads I can have the snares on
and it's not too loud but it still has
sort of the snare feel right so yes it
is indeed a snare drum in the background
and maybe maybe I would play it at some
point although just playing a snare drum
it's not it's not the most exciting
thing that you can do you know on a live
stream but it's something I would be I'd
be willing to entertain that I guess if
if nothing else okay what's on the
program tomorrow so we did an interview
but let me tell you about a couple
things actually today on the program I
interviewed a guy named William Gardner
okay and William Gardner is a
right-winger and part one of the
interview was broadcast on today's
broadcast show part two of the interview
will be tomorrow part two of the
interview gets very confrontational
specifically on the issues of gay
marriage and multiculturalism okay so I
would highly encourage you to check out
this interview on YouTube when is it
that that interview goes live with
William Gardner it's a good
old-fashioned right-winger debate which
we've not had for a little while
ah okay so we're the the interview
doesn't go live on YouTube until the end
of the week well okay if you're a member
you can check out this interview through
the member portal you can also listen to
the podcast the interviews on the
podcast but this is a really really good
interview that I think you're going to
enjoy tomorrow on the show we're going
to talk about the cognitive dissonance
that is it's sort of I I don't want to
use medical language but it seems to
have infected many trumpets I told you
last week that despite the reality that
Donald Trump jr. admitted to meeting in
Trump Tower
with that Russian lawyer something like
half of all Trump is
still don't believe that he met with
that Russian lawyer trumpet Trump jr.
admitted to it right we also have half
of Trump voters according to a new poll
believe Donald Trump won the popular
vote Donald Trump actually lost the
popular vote by what in a presidential
election is considered a huge margin
Trump lost the popular vote three to
five million people didn't vote
illegally for Hillary Clinton Trump does
loss straight up and yet his propaganda
around that his fake news one might call
it has really worked because half of his
supporters believe that he won the
popular vote I'm also going to talk
about the very awkward situation that
Donald Trump finds himself in now
because there are threats now from
Russia and from Iran that things are not
going to be good for the United States
if new sanctions are imposed on Russia
now the House of Representatives has
recently voted not only on a new
sanctions package against Russia but
also on a limitation against Donald
Trump's power to ease sanctions on
Russia
so Trump is going to find himself in
this situation where on the one hand
Republicans and Democrats in the house
are moving forward on this sanctions
package which also limits Trump's power
as far as that goes
and on the other hand you've got Russia
which Donald Trump clearly is very very
connected to saying if you sanction us
further there will be consequences so
this is increasingly a awkward situation
for Donald Trump and I think that it's
going to be an interesting couple of
weeks two months and this actually gets
to another announcement I wanted to make
I just want to prepare you for when it
happens we will be going on David Pakman
show summer vacation for the last let me
see it's the last two full weeks of
August it's it's the second and third
full week it's it's kind of awkward
because August starts on the 31st and
August ends on a Thursday but I guess
what I mean is the week
starting the 14th and 21st we will be on
david pakman show summer vacation and we
are preparing a number of long-form
deep-dive investigative videos for you
for during that time and some YouTube
only bonus content and a lot of stuff so
there will be no shortage of content
during that time but I just feel like
we're gonna go on vacation and it's
going to absolutely implode with Trump
and everything will come to a head
I hope that you know if that happens I
will stream live no doubt about it I
will be visiting family in Argentina
it's only a 1 hour time difference from
us east coast so there will not be some
weird timezone issue that will prevent
me from commenting on what's going on
but it's always better to be in studio
and focused on the show when the major
news breaks but there's kind of major
news every single day under this
administration let's go back into the
super chat then we'll get to some
thank-yous by the way just real quick
the challenge is to get us to 1850
patrons before the end of the stream if
we get to 1850 patrons at patreon.com
slash david pakman show I will create
and release a 56 % discount code just
for you wonderful viewers on the YouTube
live stream and a few people have
already made their contribution so keep
those coming in and hopefully we'll get
to 1850 the preaching show has sent a $5
super chat keep up the good work and
beware of Sinclair broadcasting taking
over local media yeah and in fact let me
do a search for something yeah so I
believe that Sinclair Broadcast Group
basically bought I might be wrong here I
did a quick Google search Western
Massachusetts where we started the David
Pakman show 10 years ago there were
three local news stations and I believe
that Sinclair now owns all three of them
and if you watch it in a half-hour you
get you know nine minutes eight minutes
of commercials that gets us down to 22
minutes you've got like six minutes of
weather that gets us down to 60
it's in a half-hour and then you've got
a whole bunch of these nationally
produced packages so how much local news
is actually on the local news it's very
very little it's it's both sad and
low-energy
and you've got to be a bad or sick in
parentheses guy at Sinclair broadcasting
to be doing that to people and I should
talk more about Sinclair broadcasting
group says II Canales has sent a fifteen
dollar super chat with the message peace
thank you says he very much appreciate
that Frank macwrite has sent the twenty
dollar super chat what if Hillary had
all of this Russia activity this early
on what if Obama gave the same speech at
the Boy Scouts event with all this
hypocrisy do you see normalization of
the lack of decency from future
candidates yeah so number one Frank if
Obama or Hillary did two percent of the
things that Trump did Republicans would
be calling for the death penalty against
Obama or against Hillary Clinton number
two
hypocrisy doesn't matter in the sense
that if you care about hypocrisy you're
against Trump right now you either
didn't vote for him in November or you
voted for him in November and have since
realized that we're dealing with a
nutjob here
so hypocrisy doesn't matter in the sense
that if you're still concerned if you're
still not concerned about hypocrisy if
you're still supporting Trump you don't
care about hypocrisy I guess is the
point that if making I'm making and
lastly do I see Trump possibly leading
to the normalization of this type of
candidate in the future yeah I think so
and you know I did a big takedown of
demmick what I call Democrats Inc on the
broadcast show today and hopefully
you'll check out that video when it
publishes to YouTube and in fact let me
see when that video will be publishing
and if Democrats don't get there you
know what together we could be dealing
with president kid Rock or Ted Cruz
sooner than later and that interview
that clip will be going live at midnight
Eastern tonight okay so check that out
later today or maybe
tomorrow Jennifer karein has sent a $20
super check Jennifer Koran who
graciously sponsored for free
memberships early on in July Jennifer
says hey David do you think what Nixon
did is worse than what we think Trump
and his minions have done every single
day things seem to get crazier I hope
you got enough money where you don't
need YouTube revenue yeah so listen I
think that we don't there's really no
answer to that question right now
I am absolutely sure that what the in
total has been done by Trump and his
aides and staffers in total definitely
it has the potential to be worse than
what Nixon did and I hope my only my
desire is that someday we'll find out
the truth to ATZ turbo has sent a $5
super Chad what do you make of the poll
which had Kid Rock up four points over
incumbent Michigan senator Davies debbie
Stabenow how should Democrats fight back
against him it's funny that you
mentioned Kid Rock because I just
mentioned Kid Rock yeah I mean I think
Trump has a role to play in that right
Donald Trump has normalized outrageous
clueless politics as sort of an
acceptable platform if you're
anti-establishment or willing to say
things that others aren't willing to say
so that I think it is directly related
to Donald Trump says he Canales
following up with another $10 Super chat
no question or comment thank you very
much Susie Toni Merritt has sent a five
British Pound Super chat if Jeff
Sessions were to resign or be fired who
do you reckon would be likely to replace
him over at the Young Turks they were
suggesting Ted Cruz you know Trump has
this tendency to move away from the sort
of celebrity senators or governor's type
thing like he met with Mitt Romney he
met with Chris Christie ultimately he
did make the appointment of Rick Perry
to Secretary of Energy I think it's
certainly possible that it could be Ted
Cruz but it also could be someone
much less well known to us that krump
believes would basically be a pond I
mean I think the risk would Ted Cruz is
that he might actually have some
independence that he wants to assert and
Trump's not really looking for that
right now you know Trump's not really
interested in that okay let me do some
thank yous we have a number of new
members of course if you want a
membership and the benefits of
membership are endless but the main ones
are you that you get access to the daily
members only bonus show and you get the
commercial-free all-access pass which
includes Members Only audio and video
streams of the entire show and just as
an example of what that means if you are
not a member
today's broadcast hour is released in
tidbits to you every 90 minutes from
4:00 p.m. Eastern to midnight Eastern
and some clips over the weekend if you
were a member I'm just saying if you
were a member the entire 50 minute show
would have been available to you at 4:00
p.m. Eastern today no waiting around for
individual clips to publish and that's
also available in an audio format so new
members who I want to say thank you to
Jennifer Valentino Thank You Jennifer
really really appreciate you signing up
Mike Ferrer thank you for signing up
Mike Marc Ferrer rather not Mike signing
up at david pakman.com slash membership
for a level 2 monthly membership mark
going above and beyond and Edwin Bretton
Edwin Bretton signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership if you want
the coupon if you want the discount you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 but I will mention to you if
40 percent discount is not good enough
and you would rather 56 percent discount
off of membership we've got a challenge
going right now if we get to 1850
patrons by the end of this live stream I
will create and release just for you a
56 percent discount code we started the
live stream with
and 33 patrons thanks to the generous $2
pledge from quien nuyen and the $1
pledge from richard moore gazing we now
have or maybe more geese is the way he
pronounces it
we now are up to 1836 and that doesn't
make sense I'm missing one name there
whose name might I be missing well it'll
catch up have not gotten a notification
about that third patron we are at 1836
14 patrons to go 14 patrons to go help
everybody out folks if we can get just
14 more patrons everybody will have the
benefit of being able to sign up for
david pakman show membership at a 56
percent discount 56 percent discount
help us get there just 14 patrons to go
okay a lot more questions coming in here
via the super chat the Prince of presto
Nia has sent a $5 super chat thinking
about Trump speaking at the Jamboree
makes me feel like I got kicked in my
khaki shorts yeah I know what you mean
Prince I I did a story today I was about
a day behind on that story because we
had the full hour interview with Dave
Rubin yesterday the entire the the video
goes live at 9:00 p.m. and I call that
Trump loses his mind at Boy Scout rally
Boy Scouts bail the speech that Donald
Trump gave at that Boy Scout rally was
not only inappropriate because we're
talking about kids were not trying to
give a political speech or at least past
presidents have not have opted not to do
that it's a totally unhinged speech and
it continues to suggest when I got a
bunch of emails after that happened
where people said David I am
increasingly convinced that your
hypothesis of Donald Trump having the
early signs of dementia is true because
he was rambling lees incoherent at that
boyscout speech so yeah it was bizarre
Prince absolutely bizarre repentant
gamer has sent a $5 super chat saying
Ruben's classical liberal arguments
yesterday reminded me of four legs good
two legs bad from Animal Farm low on
substance high on slogans well it
depends gamer or repentant I don't know
if how I should refer to you that
depends on what your perspective is if
your perspective is one that aligns with
Dave Rubens view then you probably saw
the generalities that he spoken as a
good thing because he was laying out
sort of the broader reality of the you
know political and economic system or
something if you wanted to dig into the
nitty-gritty and and you found that the
lack of detail was problematic then you
probably came away with the idea that
you that you're sort of presenting
they're so diverse diverse views on that
no doubt about that
Frank macwrite has sent the $20 superjet
I subscribe caught the live show before
watching today's show
Democrats messaging sounds like charity
we're gonna do this for you it should be
we're going to help you do this we need
empowerment not favors what are your
thoughts yeah I don't know I mean that
trying to think about that I've been
very critical of this new a better deal
strategy and the specific issues that
Democrats say they want to take on with
this better deal and the camel Harris
Kamala
Kamla I always forget how to pronounce
it any a camel Harris senator from
California donors already flocking to
her and talking about how she's so great
and she's gonna run a centrist campaign
when the last thing Democrats need after
2016 is a centrist campaign
I actually am not so concerned with what
you're pointing out Frank I think it's a
fair criticism but I don't believe that
it's gonna be as electoral disastrous as
what I've seen Democrats do so far okay
so yeah interesting but I I'm not as
concerned as you are about that but I
appreciate your support Frank is indeed
a subscriber also a super chat all-star
Frank has already thrown in 40 bucks
just during this live stream right if
you can do just $1 that's all I'm asking
from you if you help us get to 1850
patrons before the end of the stream I
will create and release a secret coupon
code for membership 56 percent off okay
56 percent off if you can help get us to
1850 patrons okay more super chats a lot
of super chats coming in Athena Harding
has sent a 15 dollar super chat as much
as I'd like to see sessions gone I don't
think he will resign or be fired he
seems so determined to push his hawkish
agenda that he would endure all the
humiliation from Trump I well I don't
think he will resign or be fired that's
two separate things it would be his
decision to resign it would be Trump's
decision to fire him although sometimes
people are forced into resignation as we
saw with disgraced National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn I actually
disagree with the Athena I have a hard
time imagining how session stays if
sessions does stay it's basically a [ __ ]
show from here on out and I believe
ultimately sessions will depart I hope
that it is not from resignation I hope
that it is from a firing which would
make Donald Trump look even worse
Athena Harding following up her $15
Super chat with a $10 super chat I
didn't have enough characters to finish
Joshua Green had some good points on why
he thinks sessions won't leave on
Democracy Now okay that's fair I'll
check that out and see sort of what I
gather from that Mike Locke has sent a
$1 super chat with no question or
comment and I say thank you and I
appreciate that for people who want to
get involved beyond just you know I get
emails from people who have said David
you know it's since you brought in the
moderators on the YouTube live streams
I'm actually enjoying the chat it just
moves so quickly sometimes
I can't even really engage in discussion
I would suggest to you if you want to
engage in discussion with other David
Pakman show viewers and listeners head
on over to our reddit discussion forum
we have a subreddit on the main reddit
web site you can access an easily by
going to david pakman.com slash reddit
as of right now we have three thousand
nine hundred and nine of our viewers and
listeners who are i think we've got a
blinking light here that's about to go
out just saw that in the reflection
nearly four thousand of our viewers and
listeners are participating in
discussions some of the really
interesting conversations that are on
there there's a report that trump and
jeff sessions are no longer speaking to
one another that's interesting there's a
question about if you could live
anywhere in the US and money was not an
issue where would you live which is an
interesting conversation given that cost
of living is a consideration for a lot
of people there were some revelations
about how producer pat has moved on to
cold brew coffee off of his Keurig on
today's broadcast show there are already
questions about Pat's cold brew
technique and equipment on our reddit
discussion forum there are discussions
about health care discussions about the
Dave Rubin interview a very good
conversation about transgender
individuals in the military so if you're
eager for moderated conversation
conversation I would encourage you to go
over to david pakman.com slash read it a
lot of really good stuff going on over
there and it's moderated by some of the
same great people that are moderating
the YouTube chat so it's all good it's
all good what's happening there and I
encourage you to check that out okay we
are closing in on 1850 patreon donors
and we are also closing in on the end of
the live stream the question is which
will happen first because eighteen
hundred and fifty donors will trigger a
major coupon code just for you Kenny
quant has pledged five dollars per month
Thank You Kenny Kenny going five times
above and beyond what it is I'm asking
which is just one dollar a month if you
can spare it
Alex Bramwell has pledged two dollars
per month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and Mandy McChesney has
pledged two dollars a month at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show
which gets us to 1839 patrons we are 11
patrons away from the target and you
know I I really want this to succeed I
really want to do the 56% Monday we
reached our goal of 1,800 and I did a
55% coupon code for membership I really
want to get to the 56% coupon code this
time around so I encourage you to help
us get there also I want to say thank
you to Kristin Racine who has signed up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership Kristin opting not to wait
for any damn coupon codes just signing
up a david pakman.com slash membership
straight away
thanks so much Kristin really really
appreciate it and appreciate everybody
who's really come to our rescue in a
sense in the wake of the advertiser
boycott that's happening on YouTube the
preaching show has sent a subsequent
super chat to dollar super chat why is
the right-wing so out of control I mean
that's several hours worth of answers
there there's a couple different things
going on first you've had the Republican
Party invaded sort of like destroyed
from the inside out by the Donald Trump
presidency by the alt-right and by
Trumpets
you've also seen the right-wingers who
are not trumpets increasingly eager to
get stuff done under the cover of the
constant scandal of the Trump
administration and we've seen that
happen since January 20th Trump's
inauguration and I've been doing my best
to continue to report to you on what is
going on it's really a combination of
factors and then you also you know you
should see the emails I get from
from bists there is starting to be some
degree of desperation from people who
are starting to wonder whether this is
all going to implode on Trump and that's
also causing the right to become even
more belligerent Vanguard commander has
sent a five-dollar super chat do you
think Donald Trump will really fire Jeff
Sessions it seems like a bad move yeah I
think that PR wise it would be a
disaster for Trump particularly if the
goal is to put in some other Attorney
General who will not be recused on
Russia and who might be able to run
interference with the special prosecutor
when it comes to the Russia
investigation but I do think that it is
a very very risky move I hope that he
does do it because it will just grow the
scandal even more Martin Anderson has
sent a hundred Norwegian kroner super
chat saying hi David I'm from Norway so
I don't understand your politics but I
can't really fathom how such a
ridiculous person is perceived as a
serious person by a big portion of the
electorate in your country yeah you know
every time Martin that I report on the
new lows of Donald Trump's approval
rating my surprise is not how low his
approval rating is it's how high his
approval rating is because even a 35 36
percent that still means that you know
forgetting geographical differences if
you just randomly talk to three people
in the United States three adults one of
them will say I approve of the job
president Trump is doing and that is
where I share your disbelief and when
I've been traveling in Europe since the
election I can only assume when I get to
visit my family in Argentina next month
your view is shared by many around the
world and my my shock is that Donald
Trump's approval rating is as high as it
is not that it's at record lows because
it should be at record lows Paul greets
Paul grete has sent a $5 super chat with
no question or comment thanks very much
Paul I appreciate that the preaching
show competing with Frank McCrae
as for the position of super chat MVP
sending another $5 super chat long live
David Pakman you do a valuable service
just like John Oliver preaching show
thank you by the way what is preaching
show mean I'm actually going to click
over to the preaching shows channel like
are they running an actual preaching
show okay preaching show has five videos
one subscriber and one of them is called
God's love explained all right well
listen we we don't usually have the
strongest support from the religious
community but we appreciate everybody
support so the preaching show thanks for
the kind words and thanks of course for
the super chat support throughout the
throughout the livestream let's update
where we are here in our quest for 1850
we started the broadcast with 1833
patreon patrons patreon is the simplest
way to help us recover from the
destructive effect of the YouTube
advertiser boycott which has taken us on
a rollercoaster ride from everything
being fine earlier in the year at point
one on this graph this revenue graph all
the way down to point to the beginnings
of a recovery at point three and
ultimately to an eighty five percent
deficit in YouTube ad revenue at point
four and my challenge to you has been if
we can get just seventeen people to make
a pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show doesn't have to be a big
pledge it can be just a dollar a month
if we can get seventeen people to do it
that will get us to 1850 and if that
happens if we get to 1850 patreon donors
I will create and denounce only to you I
won't talk about this anywhere else just
for you a 56 percent discount code for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership I am pleased to tell you that
we have just received another pledge
from d'Alene Triplett
Delaine Triplett has made a pledge of $2
per month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show that gets us to 1840 patrons
we have roughly 10 minutes left in this
livestream and we have ten patrons to go
before we get to 1850 it is in your
hands folks it is in your hands if
you're interested in this 56 percent
discount off of membership we just need
10 more even as little as $1
contributions at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show let me tell you about some
of the long-form investigations deep
dives as I like to call them that we
have ready to go any day now we are
going to be coming to you with a deep
dive into the violent left the violent
left is the new talking point from some
on the right the left is so violent the
left is so angry the left is is looting
and doing destruction of property the
problem of political violence is on the
left I am here to tell you it is not and
we have done a really good long-form
piece on this that our intern Brian has
done the background research on our
producer Noah has done the editing on
and producer Pat and I are working on
when exactly that will be scheduled form
really good piece that's the type of
thing we can only do if we replace the
lost revenue from the YouTube advertiser
boycott we have in production a really
good piece on classical liberalism
particularly in light of yesterday's
hour-long interview with Dave Rubin
arguably one of the most prominent on
YouTube classical liberals of 2017 we've
got a really good piece on classical
liberalism
and I'm calling it classical liberalism
is really effing conservative that's the
title that I have in mind for it I think
you're really going to like that we are
also working on two additional pieces
one called
debunked socialism has never worked I am
NOT a socialist but I think it's
important if we're going to talk about
economic systems we
have a good sense of the history of
those economic systems and so we have a
video called debunked socialism has
never worked and in producer Noah's
working on that former intern Kermit
producer Noah we also have current
intern Brian working on one a long-form
video on voter suppression and voter ID
which is really really good as well okay
so we've got those in production
currently and then the next step is that
we have a long form of deep dive into
race and IQ plan for you as well as a
critical thinking miniseries the
critical thinking miniseries it really
just depends on on whether there's
demand for the continued growth of the
David Pakman show the critical thinking
miniseries the research is about 75%
done it would be a twelve to fifteen
part series I think it is acutely needed
right now okay acute we needed but it is
a ton of work to in addition to a five
day a week broadcast show to do a twelve
to fifteen piece miniseries on critical
thinking I would like to do it so those
are some of the things that we have
planned and of course if you have
long-form videos that you want to
suggest there is a sticky thread on our
reddit discussion forum where you can
propose long-form videos let's look
again at the Super chats we've got a two
British Pound super chat from KLM much
appreciated thank you thank you so much
for your support we are trying to get to
1850 patrons before the end of this
stream we have just received another
pledge from Paul Thompson who has
pledged $1 per month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show you might be
saying to yourself I'm not gonna bother
because I could only pledge $1 a month
wrong exact wrong perspective if you can
pledge $1 a month you're actually more
than making up for the lost revenue from
any individual Youtube subscriber as a
result of the YouTube ad boycott so it
is exactly those dollar pledges that
will
get us there we are nine away we are at
1841 patreon pledges we've only got
about five minutes left of the
livestream if we get nine more pledges
and get to 1850 I will create a 56
percent discount coupon code just for
you I won't announce it anywhere else it
will be available for you to take a of
but we've got to get to 1850 patrons in
order for me to do that it wouldn't be
fair if I made a challenge and then we
didn't hit that number and I still
release the coupon code right I've got
to stick to it in the meantime let's get
back to the super chat Toni Merritt with
a five British Pound super chat saying
what did Tony Merritt say what do you
reckon it would take to make the whole
of fox news turn on Trump sometimes I
feel that Hannity would defend him even
if he shot someone yeah I think that
what that's going you started to see
elements of Fox News be not against
Trump but at least more connected to
reality so let Chris Wallace is one
example Shep Smith is one example where
every once in a while we will get not
anti Trump but just based in reality so
I think that if the Republican party if
Republican insiders Senators Congressmen
broadly start to become more anti Trump
that is when you might see Fox News
become more anti Trump now whether that
will include Hannity or not I don't know
I don't know okay update on patreon
Christina Dee just pledged a dollar a
month and we also received a huge $5 a
month pledge from Anthony so wet or so
tea so Eddie I'm not sure exactly how
that's pronounced I apologize if I'm if
I'm butchering it that gets us to 1843
patrons we are now only 7 patrons away 7
patrons away from 1850 1850 patrons will
trigger will trigger a 56% discount
pun code off of membership if that's
interesting we just need seven more
seven more $1 pledges gets us there back
to the super chet Martin Anderson has
sent 250 Norwegian kroner super chat
saying thank you for the reply I'm not
disturbed by Trump as I am by the people
who believe him
hope you get by with your revenue
problem regarding YouTube best of luck
very interesting very interesting right
Trump is one guy and yeah he's bonkers
but the problem is as I said earlier
more than a third of the country still
thinks Trump is doing a good job and
that is incredibly scary incredibly
incredibly scary
Paul grete has sent a $5 super check
classical liberal here I appreciate your
honesty
I did have a question but it's too long
to articulate here
I will surely email Thanks thank you
Paul I look forward to receiving that
question the d2j bug has sent a ten
Canadian dollar super chat saying c is
for cookie that's good enough for me
alright thank you
d2j bug appreciate that Kristin Racine
sent a $5 super chat saying I finally
got membership sorry it took so long
been watching for a few months you're my
favorite t whitey ah
we have no affiliation with you i T
whatsoever so I don't know if that is
bad
I mean don't cancel your membership
because we're not part of T YT but we
have no affiliation with T YT I have
many friends at T YT but we have we are
completely independent no affiliation
with T YT whatsoever
checking back in to our challenge on
patreon we are looking to hit 1850
patrons by the end of the stream which
is coming up very quickly we started
with 1833 patrons patrons we are at 1844
patrons we are 6 patrons away thanks to
Rachel fish Bynes $2 a month pledge
rachel thank you very much 6 patrons
folks we're getting down to the wire
this live stream will end soon I would
love it
if we got to 1850 and then I would
create and release a 56% discount code
off of membership if you're not
interested in that by all means there's
no need to do it but I think it would be
really great Trump will be impeached
2017 has sent a $20 super chat with no
question or comment maybe their question
or comment is that they believe Donald
Trump will be impeached in 2017
davide vent Romi has sent a five
Canadian dollar super chat
Ruben's labeling of himself Dave Reubens
labeling of himself as a classic liberal
while supporting single-payer health
care fascinates I don't think he sees
the issue with that yeah I actually in
thinking back to yesterday's interview
with Dave Rubin one of the most
interesting parts for me was the
conversation about health care and about
Dave Rubin saying that he as he's
classically liberal but he supports
single-payer health care but at the same
time the health care system he described
as ideal is really more of an Obama care
type system not single-payer I thought
that that was a really interesting part
Pramod bhuva Bhuvan car or boov on car
has sent a $2 super chat saying people
interested in classic liberalism check
Sam cedar that's interesting that's
interesting
I mean Sam cedar is not a classical
liberal as far as I know and I know Sam
pretty well but has maybe he's done some
critiques or criticisms of classical
liberalism I'm not sure I'm not sure but
I think that that is Sam's always doing
interesting stuff so not a bad
recommendation I believe folks that we
may not achieve 1850 patrons to give you
it I I'm gonna try to just give one more
opportunity for this to happen here
because I would rather us succeed rather
than fail we lost 85 percent of our
YouTube ad revenue as a result of what's
known as ad pocalypse on YouTube and as
a result of that we need new
sources of revenue one of those sources
is called patreon patreon allows
individuals to go to patreon.com/scishow
and simply by hitting the red button
that says become a patron you can throw
us as little as $1 a month
okay we need this in order to make up
for the revenue that we have lost we
started today with 1833 patrons just an
hour ago at the beginning of this
livestream I put out the challenge that
if we can get to 1850 patrons which
requires only 17 new patrons right not
an out-of-this-world thing considering
the hundreds and hundreds of people that
have cycled in and out through the live
stream over the last hour if we get to
1850 patrons by the end of the stream I
will create and announce to you a coupon
code that you can use on our website
which will give you a fifty six percent
discount this is slightly better than
the fifty five percent discount that we
achieved by hitting 1,800 patrons on
Monday the bad news is that we are very
close to the end of this livestream and
yet we have managed to get only within
six patrons of where we are trying to be
we are at 1844 patrons and I know that
some people might say well David you
should create the coupon code anyway I
think that if we issue a challenge we
should stick to the challenge and sadly
I don't know that we are going to make
it to 1850 today although I would love
it if we did I would love it if we did
upcoming interviews on the program that
I want to tell you about just as I give
a little more time to see if we can get
to 1850 patrons I think that there are
some really interesting interviews
coming up Michael Wood jr. former police
officer Michael Wood Jr who has made
quite a name for himself as a law
enforcement reform advocate he is going
to be joining me on Monday next Monday
we will speak to Michael Wood jr. I will
also be interviewing a
Tuesday Peter Bogosian and Peter
Boghossian is a guy that has sort of
been he's been overlapping in a number
of different worlds lately he is in the
skeptic world he is in the sort of anti
safe space anti trigger warning world
he's also sort of in the day of Reuben
universe we're gonna be speaking to
Peter pegasion next Tuesday and then on
Wednesday I'm going to be interviewing
Sarah Levin and Sarah Levin is going to
talk to us about some really really
disturbing happenings in the world of
chep separation of church and state
separation of church and state is under
attack not religion is under attack
quite the opposite
separation of church and state is under
attack under the Trump administration
and we're going to be talking about that
with Sarah Levin that is most of next
week then we've got the full week after
that of all brand-new shows and then we
will be on David Pakman show summer
vacation but don't worry there is plenty
of stuff planned for the YouTube channel
during that vacation and on that note
sadly we have not reached eighteen
hundred and fifty patreon donors today I
hope that next time we will be able to
reach our target and I will be able to
deliver to you a huge huge membership
discount all right that's it for today
great program coming up tomorrow thanks
to everybody who joined me